wie werden roboter unser leben verändern
haben roboter gefühle und wenn ja
sollten wir sie trotzdem in battles
gegeneinander antreten lassen
die antworten auf alle fragen findet ihr
nach dem intro roboter helfen uns
heutzutage in beinahe jeder lebenslage
ob im auto beim einkauf auf reisen oder
bei der herstellung von unseren
produkten
viele dieser roboter sind keine
eigenständige wesen sie haben keine
körper sie existieren nur auf einer
festplatte und müssen von uns herum
getragen und bedient werden
trotzdem treffen diese maschinen jeden
tag entscheidungen für uns klar sind das
oft auch triviale entscheidung nämlich
jetzt die landstraße oder die autobahn
welche e-mails sind spam und welche von
freunden am 6 mai 2010 fand in den usa
der wohl schnellste börsencrash aller
zeiten statt
innerhalb von 36 minuten brach der wert
des dow jones um 9 prozent ein und
erholte sich fast genauso schnell wieder
die ursache war wahrscheinlich ein
einzelner händler der mit hilfe eines
computerprogramms dem verkauf viele
aktien vortäuschte die algorithmen der
wall street reagierten automatisch auf
diese angebote und innerhalb von minuten
lang und sank der gesamte markt es kann
also durchaus auch negative konsequenzen
haben wenn nicht mehr menschen sondern
maschinen die entscheidungen über unser
leben treffen in vielen laboren und
werkstätten dieser welt wird gerade
daran getüftelt richtige roboter also
die mit armen und beinen noch
vielseitiger einsetzbar zu machen und
die erfolgreichsten dieser modelle gehen
dann zur data challenge bei diesem
turnier treten teams von ingenieuren und
wissenschaftlern mit ihren robotern
gegeneinander an
wohnviertel
nein nicht so die roboter müssen eine
reihe von aufgaben erledigen darunter
autofahren türen öffnen treppensteigen
und löcher bohren
die allermeisten maschinen in unserem
leben sind gut und effizient in genau
einer sache können aber eigentlich
nichts anderes bei der darpa challenge
geht es aber darum maschinen für
möglichst viele einsatzzwecke zu
entwickeln
sie könnten dann zum beispiel bei
katastrophen in krisengebieten helfen
ohne zusätzliche menschenleben zu
gefährden
im moment machen wir noch über roboter
die in einer halben stunde nicht mal
eine tür geöffnet kriegen aber wie das
mooresche gesetz zeigt ist es nur eine
frage der zeit bis sich die technik
weiterentwickelt
inzwischen sind autonome autos schon
tausende von kilometern unfallfrei
gefahren
und genau so werden auch roboter
irgendwann in der zukunft besser laufen
klettern und fahren können als wir
selbst
boston dynamics eine firma die sich auf
das entwickeln von robotern
spezialisiert hat wurde 2013 von google
aufgekauft im jahr 2005 entwickelte das
unternehmen für das us-militär big dog
einen vierbeinigen roboter für soldaten
er soll in kampfgebieten zusätzliche
ausrüstung für die truppen tragen und
von hier aus ist es nicht mehr weit bis
die laufenden robotern waffen einbauen
und sie in den krieg schicken
das mag am anfang noch sinnvoll klingt
schließlich ist es viel besser eine
maschine zu verlieren als ein
menschenleben
aber hier fangen die moralischen
probleme auch schon an wer entscheidet
über leben und tod
bei den kontroversen kampfdrohnen sitzen
immer noch menschen vom computer und
entscheiden über den abschuss wenn der
algorithmus eines roboters entscheiden
soll wann die waffe abgefeuert wird
haben wir vielleicht bald schlimmere
konsequenzen als den flash crash an der
börse mit genau diesen fragen
beschäftigt sich die kampagne gegen
killer roboter die organisation weist
darauf hin dass viele experten vor dem
einsatz von autonomer künstlicher
intelligenz warnen
darunter sind auch stephen hawking und
ihnen mas es geht dabei nicht um
sogenannte schwache künstliche
intelligenz die art die nur eine aufgabe
erledigen kann
die amazon bordrestaurant roboter oder
room bar wobei rumors sowohl staubsauger
als auch katzen transportsystem sind wie
auch immer diese art von software obwohl
sie auch entscheidungen trifft ist nicht
das problem
es sind dinge wie der supercomputer
watson oder googles die streaming
algorithmen die lernen können sich
ständig selber verbessern und so
irgendwann einen punkt erreichen an dem
sie die menschlichen
denn zu überholen experten nennen diesen
punkt die technologische singularität
das hier ist baxter erst ein
selbstständig lernen der roboter seine
algorithmen sind darauf ausgelegt dass
ihm arbeitsschritte gezeigt werden die
er dann nachahmen kann besser soll vor
allem monotone aufgaben in fabriken
erledigen und kostet weniger als ein
fabrikarbeiter pro jahr
es ist nicht schwer sich vorzustellen
wie viele arbeitsplätze durch baxter und
ähnliche roboter in den nächsten zehn
bis 20 jahren wegfallen werden
und es sind nicht nur die jobs für die
man oft keine ausbildung benötigt sogar
höchst renommierte berufe wie arzt oder
anwalt müssen sich gedanken machen
bereits jetzt arbeitet der supercomputer
watson an einer riesigen medizinischen
datenbank um das diagnostizieren von
patienten zu erleichtern und zu
verbessern und auch hier kann man sich
vorstellen wie patienten von einem
roboter gescannt und befragt werden
die ergebnisse laufen dann durch watsons
algorithmus und das ergebnis wird nur
noch kurz von einem menschlichen arzt
gegengecheckt und genauso wie menschen
auf beruflicher ebene bei durch roboter
ersetzt werden könnte uns das auf
emotionaler ebene auch passieren die so
genannten social boards sind gemacht um
uns in unserem alltag zu unterstützen
und dabei eine beziehung zu ihrem
besitzer aufzubauen
in einer welt in der pädophile im
internet chats bereits durch künstliche
intelligenz ausfindig gemacht werden
können kann man sich auch schon die
erste roboter mensch beziehung
vorstellen
per ex machina und hunderte andere filme
lassen grüßen
roboter mit künstlicher intelligenz
haben eine menge potenzial uns zu helfen
das ganze kann aber auch gewaltig in die
hose gehen wir müssen also genau
aufpassen wie weit wir gehen und was wir
mit unseren robotern machen aber es wäre
ja schade wenn wir nicht zumindest eine
sache über roboter genießen könnten oder
lohberg
nächstes jahr soll der roboter der us
firma mega bots incorporated gegen den
japanischen rover von tsuyoshi heavy
industry antreten und zwar bis zum tod
oder bis zum totalausfall
wer also nicht lange genug warten kann
bis sich roboter in echten kriegen
bekämpfen kann das projekt auf
kickstarter unterstützen link dazu unten
in der video beschreibung genau so wie
der link zu quälen und zu einem
geheimprojekt von mir
was meint ihr sind autonome roboter mit
künstlicher intelligenz fluch oder segen
sollten wir sie verbieten oder weiter
erforschen diskutiert ist wie immer mit
mir unten in den kommentaren
ansonsten findet ihr hier meine beiden
letzten videos von nordson wie
funktioniert eigentlich ein jetpack in
der mitte und darunter was kommt nach
dem touchscreen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
gibt mir doch bitte einen daumen nach
oben und schickt es an eure freunde
weiter wir sehen uns nächste woche bis
dahin